impossible d'authentifier ces images qui
tournent depuis ce matin sur les réseaux
sociaux russes l'engin qui explose
au-dessus du Kremlin serait un drone la
présidente russe n'a pas perdu de temps
pour pointer du doigt ce qu'elle estime
responsable de cette attaque
la nuit dernière le régime de Kief a
tenté de frapper le Kremlin avec des
drones deux drones visaient le Kremlin
les engins ont été mis hors service
grâce à l'utilisation de système radars
de guerre électronique nous considérons
ces actions comme une tentative d'acte
terroriste et un attentat contre la vie
du président
Moscou ajoute que Vladimir Poutine qui
est réapparu dans la journée dans sa
résidence proche de Moscou ne se
trouvait pas au Kremlin au moment des
fées en visitant Finlande le président
ukrainien ni tout implication de son
pays oui
nous n'attaquons pas Poutine ou Moscou
nous nous battons sur notre territoire
nous défendons nos villages nos villes
nous n'avons pas vous savez assez
d'armes pour cela
on ne peut pas les gâcher et nous
n'avons pas attaqué Poutine nous
laissons cela pour le tribunal
le maire de Moscou annonce interdire
tout survol de la ville par des drones
le défilé du 9 mai qui commémore la
victoire russe sur l'Allemagne nazie et
lui maintenu dans la capitale
contrairement à plusieurs défilés prévus
en province le même jour notamment dans
la province de brillance que frontalière
de l'Ukraine ou deux trains de
marchandises ont été sabotés à l'aide
dans un explosifs lundi et mardi la nuit
dernière c'est un dépôt de carburant de
la région russe de Krasnodar près de la
Crimée qui a pris feu soit 5 jours après
une attaque de drone sur un autre dépôt
celui de Sébastopol en Crimée qui est
continue de garder le silence sur tous
ces événements